we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p it's been a
while since we heard from furious
trumpets jimmy from philly but he did
leave a voicemail and it was about
president bernie sanders take a listen
to this
david jimmy from philly regarding your
comment president Bernie Sanders yo okay
something about that laugh feels a
little too really maniacal I I somehow
don't think that that's a joke but in
any case I don't know what Jimmy is
referring to specifically I did say I am
a Bernie Warren guy but beyond that I
think that there is going to be plenty
of time for laughing after the election
there will be plenty of time for crying
after the election all emotions are
going to be on the table and visible
after the election but for the time
being I don't know that I have much more
of a response to Jimmy from Philly we
will talk on the bonus show today about
Hillary Clinton's very interesting
interview with Howard Stern we will talk
about that Art Basel Miami 120 thousand
dollar banana thing there are some
interesting things to talk about if you
haven't heard about it I'll tell you all
about it and a new report found that the
United States lost more tax revenue than
any other developed country in 2018
due to the Donald Trump tax cuts all of
those stories and more on the bonus show
at join pakman.com or become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show I'll
speak to you then